with any show that is set in a world
unlike our own
cgi and special effects do their part in
bringing the enchantment to screen
bloom's realistic glow surprisingly
wasn't created by cgi
we're going to share the simple and
effective way they brought our reality
into alfaya
today we're taking a behind the scenes
look to see
how the show brings the winx fairies to
life let's go
while in the show bloom tries to think
happy thoughts to bring her powers to
light
it took multiple skilled artists and a
lot of planning to bring all the detail
to her magic and particularly her
incredible transformation
while she seems to float up effortlessly
bloom is actually hooked up to a very
complex
rotating flying rig the rotation is
key in bringing the transformation magic
to life
the physicality also contributes to
making the transformation look as
realistic and magical as
possible it was abigail cohen's stunt
double who spent time in the rig
initially
exploring the choreographic
possibilities and establishing what
would translate the best to screen
once the team was happy with the
choreography it was taught
to abigail cohen so she could perform it
for the transformation
while cohen does the majority of it she
couldn't do it all on her own
so for certain bits her stunt double did
take over
then of course the fire part of what
makes the transformation
so impressive is the realistic looking
fire and glow
the creators have said it was important
to them to make sure it appeared as
though bloom was in control of the fire
that it was the power from inside of her
in order to establish this
the team had the actor holding rods with
lights on them in her hands
that someone off screen would activate
when they needed a glow to appear
afterwards in editing outlines of the
flames were marked and
added to bring it all together so the
full effect
is actually a combination of cgi and
physical glowing lights removed in
editing
credit has to be given to the incredible
video effects team at cinesite london
who made the winx world supernatural
each element the fairies have
was considered and honored in as
realistic a way as possible
the eye color changes that each fairy
experiences
lies in the same color palette as their
power this of course was accomplished
with cgi
the team had water fire
earth light air and mind to work with
what makes this show unique is the way
that the elements really do
look and feel like the elements that we
know in our world
the way the team manipulated these
elements using colors and natural
textures with the magic of alfaya
is very unique and successfully brings
the ethereal enchantment we see to
screen
it was the job of visual effects to add
in the fairy creations like
floating water orbs air movement
sprouting plants and the sparks of
electricity
viewers will notice that the force
fields the fairies move through
as well as the powers used are all
connected to the real world
and augmented in a way that brings the
magic to their world
this in part is why the visuals feel so
realistic
none of it is contrived from matter we
can't somehow understand or connect to
when it came to setting certain scenes
light bars were used to fill the room's
atmosphere
look at this scene for example we can
see
side by side how similar the two look
the cgi
added fire is really just the final
touch
one of the show's greatest
accomplishments is creating convincing
magic
without digital aid and only using the
computer generated images to add what
they couldn't safely produce
have you seen blue not recently
the burned ones are one of the most
impressive otherworldly yet
realistically created images in the wink
saga
their creation was anything but simple
the first step was creating large
prosthetics that could be scanned for
stunt actors to wear while filming
of course cgi finished the image by
making the burned ones appear eight feet
tall in damage
while it was a combined effort by the
end of editing what viewers see on
screen is actually ninety percent
effects
and just ten percent stunt actor because
of the complex and detailed approach
the burned ones demonstrate realistic
agility and physicality
while appearing like a creature from
another world of magic
and fantasy and you're a fire fairy blue
i've seen you in class i know you're
powerful fate the wink saga
is truly a combined effort between the
actors
stunt doubles visual effects artists and
cgi creation
together they bring the unique magic of
alfaya to screen
and mesmerize us how do you feel about
the way they approach the creation of
the magic elements
do you prefer tara's blooming plants or
ayesha's water orbs
let us know what you think in the
comments don't forget to make sure you
subscribe to keep up with
the things